foreign
[Music]
I don't believe it's relevant to the
21st century lesbian
you're not wearing that I just came from
work I came from Toledo I don't dress
like it I'm not here to Pedal my Wares
I'm leaving town I am too that was my
plan where are you going Tallahassee
Florida I've been unhappy that's why we
take this trip together honey babe we
get our act together together
Curly's Drive Away Pennsylvania's most
trusted name and car delivery here don't
call me curly
and your name curly my name is Curly we
just met it's too familiar
here for the car wait a minute you call
with a drop off in Tallahassee and then
these broads come in and say they're
ready to go to Tallahassee
they drive the car instead of you is
that bad bad if they find the goods
what we should see what's in here I bet
it's locked
[Music]
[Applause]
I understand that you're unhappy sir we
will find and deliver the package we
just want your friends
you cannot relate to the public which in
the service profession is a big handicap
did the two creeps find you they know we
have their stuff maybe we sell it back
shake them down all right they like
wanted or something oh no they're not in
trouble at all I'm gonna help you break
a big murder case that is about the
dumbest thing I've ever heard and I'm a
cop
away
who are you Democrats
wow you've had a full day
foreign